dunque consideratemi un pochino come se
fossi un ascensore insomma tra un blocco
e l'altro ci avviciniamo alla fine ci
avviciniamo verso verso terra e come
ogni ascensore che si rispetti io ho
portato la musica dunque da dove partire
per me musicisti l'avvento di internet è
stato un po un casino
bisogna dire la verità è stato un
problema perché di colpo tutto un
sistema che era durato sostanzialmente
un secolo si è frantumato che era il
sistema dell'industria discografica e la
vendita dei dischi e se ritornati per
paradosso
all'inizio del novecento in cui quando
si stampavano accettato quella citato
serviva per promuovere le serate è un
pochino così e adesso ci sono delle
settimane in cui per andare prima in
classifica
bastano 2 mila copie vendute una volta
il disco di platino era 100 mila copie
poi sceso 75 poi 50 e via dicendo
e arrivato internet ha fatto la
rivoluzione come l'ha fatta nella vita
di tutti noi
nella musica l'ha fatta un po prima che
in altre forme d'arte perché per esempio
per quello che riguarda i libri
nonostante il mercato sia anche lì un po
asfittico tiene ancora perché non c'è
effettivamente un alternativa che non
sia un i rider qualsiasi mentre per la
musica l'avvento delle mp3 e poi tutto
quello che è successo con le varie
piattaforme ha veramente rivoluzionato
tutto questo ha creato alcuni vantaggi
alcuni problemi è un po è stato un
pochino come se internet fosse diventato
la placenta in cui la musica è cresciuta
quindi poteva essere molto nutriente
perché ha permesso una connettività
strepitosa tra persona e quindi uno
scambio di informazioni incredibili
tanta più facilità nel fare musica e
questo lo spiegheremo tra poco ma allo
stesso tempo potrebbe essere potrebbe
essere stata anche in certi casi
quasi asfissiante perché non abbiamo
ancora trovato un metodo per muoverci
per orientarci in questa nuova giungla
ora voi lo sapete la musica e la forma
d'arte non come posso dire più
primordiale più semplice è l'unica forma
d'arte di cui nessuno di voi farà mai a
meno e tanto meno io a meno che non mi
spacchi di nuovo le mani ma al netto di
questo se una persona può passare una
vita intera non entrare in un museo a
non vedere un quadra non scegliere
consapevolmente di andare a vedere
qualcosa come diceva relatore prima è
che riguardasse che riguardi la bellezza
è tutto così non potrà essere per la
musica perché chiunque di voi è immerso
nella musica quotidianamente a una
colonna sonora e la colonna sonora della
nostra vita è fatta di tantissime
canzoni che poi fotografano e fermano
determinati momenti
chi di voi non ha utilizzato all'epoca
delle delle medie del liceo a meno che
non fosse tutti i letterati le parole di
qualche cantautore per dedicarle al
ragazzo o alla ragazza
insomma la musica direi che è quello che
ci accompagna di più arrivando alla
nuova tecnologia io l'unica cosa che mi
sono permesso di fare venendo qui per
non annoiarvi e non ammorbarvi era
quella di utilizzare l'internet of
people realmente quindi ho chiesto con
un post su facebook di mi sono aperto a
naomi sono addobbato in ordine mi sono
aperto prima una mail
tutti artisti at gmail.com e siccome era
figo così non si sente anche un pò
artista e andava bene su facebook ho
detto che avevo aperto questa mail in
questa mail avevo chiesto e ho chiesto
gentilmente per chi fosse musicista di
mandarmi qualche battuta di musica
poteva essere un big di batteria un
basso una chitarra un riff di tastiera e
qualunque cosa avessero voluto per chi
non
non ha capacità musicale ho chiesto se
potevano lasciarmi una frase e lì è
stato divertente perché oltre a una
serie di frasi che mi chiedevano come
stava il mio braccio semel avevano
amputato quant'altro sono arrivate delle
alcuni alcuni stimoli interessanti e
qualcuno qualche malato anche di
tecnologia ha fatto parlare il computer
sia con voci maschili e femminili
qualcun altro mi ha detto mi raccomando
comincia il pezzo prendendo il suono del
modem quando è arrivata la prima
connessione internet quella 54k quindi
partiamo da lì chi mi ha mandato tutti i
suoni di accensione di windows tutti
quelli di apple e quindi è stato sono
abbastanza divertente
io nel pezzo che ascolterete tra poco
che dura tre minuti nel viaggio di
questo piccolo ascensore sostanzialmente
non ho suonato una nota non ho fatto
altro che prendere questi pezzi metterli
insieme
e ho fatto anche un altra cosa c'era un
amico chitarrista che volevano
partecipare non aveva la possibilità di
essere qui oggi è con una tecnologia
nuova grazie a uno di questi software
qui mi ha registrato direttamente la sua
chitarra sul mio computer da pescara
dove stato io quindi adesso vi farò
sentire questo pezzo che è frutto di non
so quante persone e soprattutto di
persone che non ho mai conosciuto e non
ho mai visto
suonerò una tastiera che questa qualche
voi forse non vedete ma che molto
divertente perché e rispetto al discorso
della tecnologia una tastiera che ha
superato il concetto di pianoforte di
chitarra insieme a moltissimi sensori a
dei tasti quasi come quelli del
pianoforte ma si suona quasi come una
chitarra e fa dei suoni quasi da musica
elettronica
quindi c'è tutto un evolvere tutto
questo lo sono con un protocollo
bluetooth la musica vera mando dal
computer è stata fatta nel cloud tornerà
nel cloud perché poi mi piacerebbe che
somma regalare questo piccolo progetto è
che rimanga aperto quindi poi le tracce
separate di questa canzone verranno
rilasciate nell'aria poi vediamo che
cosa diventano è più che dire insomma
che questo è l'internet per noi people
della musica aggiungo solo una cosa come
c'è in una parte di testo che mi hanno
aggirato internet e consapevolezza e
responsabilità
quindi è logico che il discrimine
rimarrà sempre la persona è molto più
facile fare musica adesso lo dico da
musicista come molto più facile adesso
essere come dire o non opinion leader
magari ma opinion maker comunque farsi
dire sempre la propria su qualunque
argomento l'unico discernimento che
abbiamo è quello di essere semplicemente
noi stessi sicuramente una capacità che
in un mare così grande di informazioni
fa un po fatica ancora venir fuori però
essendo questa è una rivoluzione
irreversibile
noi continueremo darwiniana mente a
proseguire e adesso vi faccio sentire il
pezzo che ci hanno regalato
non lo so tante persone che non
conoscono
no
internet come disse qualcuno è un
cervello collettivo internet come la
musica è un linguaggio universale
in cina ris
internet è fatto delle persone
per le persone al servizio delle persone
geniali sismi in perle detto non scienza
non c'è conoscenti si sente di simili
il respons
quindi questo è veramente un applauso a
tutti quelli che hanno voglia di fare
musica
internet ha cambiato le capacità o
meglio ha tolto forse un pochino di
magia perché una volta se uno faceva il
musicista o meglio aspettava le parole
di un musicista doveva per forza
aspettare un intervista bella doveva
aspettare un servizio fotografico su un
giornale dove aspettare un disco dove
aspettare qualcosa quindi abbiamo perso
forse un pochino di magia però la magia
più grossa è questa enorme mente
collettiva che quando si mette insieme
per fare arte se riesce a essere
catalizzata in maniera intelligente darà
sempre insomma da vivere a tutte le
nostre teste
grazie a tutti e buona serata